أريد فقط أن أضغط عليك
هنا لأن الوقت ينفد
، فلنتحدث عن ذلك لبنان الجديد آه
الذي ترغب في رؤيته مبنيًا ، ما هو
شكل المستقبل للبنان في
هذه المرحلة سيدي ،
آمل أن تكون هذه هي النهاية  من
الكهرباء
التي يجب أن تتحملها في لبنان ،
أليس كذلك في
الواقع
هذا مثال على الوضع
الذي نعيش فيه بدون كهرباء
بدون
الاحتياجات الأساسية التي
اعتاد لبنان الحصول عليها وآمل أن نتمكن من
الحصول عليها بسرعة كبيرة  من
أجل القيام بذلك ، نحتاج إلى
حكام لبنان الأكفاء والأحرار لتولي زمام الأمور
ولدينا انتخابات في غضون ستة أشهر
وآمل أن يتمكن الشعب اللبناني
من
رفع صوته بحرية
وديمقراطية وسلمية
في صناديق الاقتراع و  لأكون قادرًا على أه
خلق
مستقبل جديد لهم أه سأضيف
شيئًا بسيطًا إذا سمحت لي
قبل أسبوع
صرح ضابط إيراني رسميًا أن لديهم
أربعة جيوش في المنطقة وذكر
أن حزب الله كان  أحدهم لذلك
نحن بطريقة ما في حالة احتلال
والطريقة الوحيدة للتعامل مع ذلك هي أه
رفع صوتنا إلى
المجتمع الدولي وهذا ما نقوم
به الآن أه معكم شكرًا لكم بخير
وداخليًا.  الانتخابات للحصول على
مجموعة كبيرة من البرلمانيين
المستعدين للنضال من أجل
السيادة المستقلة ولبنان حديث وديمقراطي.